barton for three
in and out
jokic scrambling for it
[Applause]
[Music]
i believe they're going to call
following nicole yokochi which is why
he's so upset
and
let's see if the nuggets
want to challenge this
it's such a tough play because it's a
loose ball foul so there's contact there
clearly but it's both players diving on
the floor you can't take them with you
will barton takes that three they're
battling underneath and then you see the
ball come out here
two okc players and jokic is just
momentum well the question is does
michael malone want to use the timeout
well jokic is bleeding again dripping
from his eye so they might need to take
a look at that anyways looks like play's
going to continue 107 105 denver
just over a minute left to play
pass underneath weak side it's mate
morris with the biggest defensive player
of the night so far
morris has been spectacular defensively
running off screens and right there
early on the help side able to deflect
it joking with 32 points
long range
yes
with a huge shot
and montre if you like
monte morris stepping up on both ends of
the floor
when denver needed it right here look at
him in the corner of your screen coming
across seeing the roll being there for
the help
jumping to make that steal it actually
went off nicole yoki's head he was able
to pull it down here and then jokic gets
doubled monte morris relocates just a
little bit higher so that jokic can see
him in that passing lane jokic threw
three thunder defenders right there
monte morris stepping in down ready to
shoot
up and it is as good as it gets folks
so right now they are working on nicola
yokic jason miller
the fight doctor trying to patch up that
eye look at that stance
down and ready
joking 32 points 12 rebounds eight
assists
and a cut you thought jokic was tough
before
playing with a
bloody eye right now he's also got a
double double which means it's double
double time at wendy's tomorrow with any
purchase you can get a free six-piece
spicy regular
whatever you please
those are some pretty great signs right
there
the nuggets fans are into it tonight
nuggets have lost four of their last
five here at ball arena trying to right
the ship monte morris a huge defensive
play and then a gargantuan three from
distance they don't call him big game
tape or nothing
40.